hello guys I'm Ryan right I am Danielle
and I are gonna check out from the Ryan
Reynolds channel of all channels
how Deadpool spent Halloween you may be
wondering why I brought you here at some
point we was all join forces become a
team now how many of you have taken a
human life what the hell's your name
rank dance come here
all right Stevie Wonder what's your
superpower that's super super power ever
heard you're not on the team I'm kidding
you're on the team what does this suit
look like to you huh does it look like a
leprechaun had sex with a cartoonist the
steep drops would give me 20 c'mere
what's your superpower control the
weather
I think that's a great way to promote
Deadpool oh my god I want it because the
movie trailer is great but this is like
really showing we got a different
comic-book hero coming our way
so excited do you think like I was just
thinking the whole time it's something
go out where they're like your kids are
gonna be in a video but be aware that
it's gonna be dirty yeah I can't tell if
that's like a skit they prepare or if
they just sent Ryan Reynolds out there
in front of these kids and like they had
to sign a release form no I'm sure
they've had it Warren
yeah my kids wouldn't know that's a fair
point you know I love about what this
really showed us is that he is Deadpool
like he's improvising this this whole
time he's got like the quick wit he's
got that he's got the mean sarcasm I
love how Ryan Reynolds is like embodying
this role and he's such a great actor -
so good did you read the comics I have
not read the comics I've seen videos
about the comics don't ever ask me that
question when we're doing a comic book
character again now I just lost the
respect that most of the audience thanks
I wonder how if ladies will still watch
it even though like he's all deformed in
it look so I'm so excited to see it it
doesn't matter about know it's better
it's better if he's deformed because
then you feel like okay you can relate
yeah I like it yeah yeah maybe it'll be
you know I'll have a chance now
yeah yeah if it's just hot the whole
time it's just I would love to see you
and Ryan Reynolds have sex so would I
yeah I would love to be in that room
maybe so to film that and I always just
be looking at him the whole time he
always does this thing when he picks the
girls up and walks with them while he's
having sex with them
oh when they pick him up oh so in three
previews I've seen so far I'm just like
holding on like not knowing what to do
Wow yeah I would let him have sex with
Veronica - that would be so cruel if you
didn't if he was like I won't have sex
with even you were like you can't Leakey
no yeah I'd be like please mister but I
have to watch you you'd have to watch
I'd have to watch what if he's not cool
then you have to watch - you have to be
involved only there was a way to make
your fantasies become a reality
I know so sad that there's just gonna be
a way I know I wish Veronica would you
gangbangs but whatever you know the
right amount of drugs alcohol mixture
can make a girl do anything you wouldn't
know you and no no guys thanks for
tuning into the channel if you're new to
it click this buddy to subscribe and
become a reject uh for tinnitus alright
alright someone finally completed it
thank you
danielle has no social media life but
she has an Instagram follow her there if
you think she's pretty
follow her on Instagram
Maiki Gonzalez I know this message will
probably never be seen what do you know
buddy we're here today but I did this
interview with I'm Dante it's not your
typical Skype interview and it turned
out to be hella fun I was wondering if
you'd be interested in a 10-question z--
Gaming interview it would mean the world
if you can check out the video it will
literally have 20 minutes of your time
that would be amazing
that'd be so fun to do a question and
answer oh yeah I've done them before I
could do this one for you Mikey Gonzales
only if you happen to come across this
video I'm not gonna reply back to this
message if you've come across this video
Mikey Gonzales I will gladly do the
interview but if you didn't I'm sorry
you're just gonna be under the
impression that I never read your
message or that I completely ignored it
well then if he doesn't look at it then
he's not really a bad exactly cuz you
have to watch every one of my [ __ ]
videos you want a shout-out you never
know when it's gonna come so you know
what remember you [ __ ] video it's a
marketing tool how do I get more people
to keep watching and I'll answer
whatever question you want Mikey like
Danielle asked me what are some
questions you would like to hear about
in an interview okay and I'll tell you
if I will answer them for Mikey what
does your typical Saturday night look
like I will share that with you right
now
strip clubs what is your go-to
restaurant ooh
Denny's no I'm sorry are you a vodka gin
man vodka oh when you drink do you
become happy angry or sad and emotional
um it's usually a mood swing of all
three how exciting yeah what a roller
coaster ride yeah at least amazing sex
with whomever at that time than if
you're sobbing I'm a great sobbing sex
guy see you'll learn a lot about me
Mikey